[Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  is not this simpler is this not your  natural state it's the unspoken truth of  humanity that you crave subjugation the  bright lure of freedom diminishes your  life's joy in a mad scramble for power  her identity you were made to be ruled  in the end you will always kneel  not to men like you their honor men like  me there are always men like you  look to your elder people let him be an  example you know the last time I was in  Germany and saw a man standing above  everybody else we ended up disagreeing  this soldier the man out of time I'm not  the one who's at a time  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  agent Romanoff you missed me  [Music]  and they can move reindeer games  mr. stark captain  you